but how did you go from that
to jackass you met tripp taylor yeah so
i met tripp taylor when i was 16 in
carlsbad california at the surf shop
that he's hanging out
wow cause he was trying to do a um show
for my friend adam knox he's putting
together a reel for him
and it was super boring until i showed
up because they called me like we got
this one kid his name's poopies he'll
[ __ ] send it so they call me up like
poopies we're gonna film something you
want to come i was like [ __ ] yeah it's
funny too because it's still on youtube
you can see how [ __ ] nervous i am i'm
like i am poopies and [ __ ] is [ __ ]
classic but i sent it for them and and
the show never got picked up
and tripped saw my success with red bull
tv and seen all this crazy [ __ ] i did
and he came to me one day he's like
poopies they're looking for new talent
for jackass i go shut the [ __ ] up
because i'm trying to get you in don't
get your hopes up i was like i'm not i'm
not and then all of a sudden i get a
call from tripp hey i got you a skype
call with knoxville and jeff germain and
i was like shut the [ __ ] up like i was
so nervous dude i was counting the days
i think i had seven days until that
skype call dude i was so [ __ ] nervous
until that moment came on then they boom
hey poopies how's it going from
knoxville and jeff jeremy i'm like what
what's up you guys like i'm freaking out
inside but we had like a 10 minute skype
call like we're flying out to la to come
do a test shoot
and it [ __ ] went fabulous and that's
when they said poopies you are made for
this yeah i wasn't there at that test no
i was like where the [ __ ] stevo yeah i
wasn't there i i was trying to uh hold
out for a better contract so i was
playing hardball with yeah playing
hardcore
and uh and but i heard from everybody
after that test shoot and everybody said
dude
this new guy poopy's is gonna be the
breakout star of this he's so [ __ ]
funny
so i heard such glowing [ __ ] about you
from that test [ __ ] dude everyone said
you were going to be it you're going to
start yeah i was a trip dude i went
there and i was like i'm not holding
back like i was volunteering for every
stunt
and they're like dude this kid's [ __ ]
is he mentally crazy
like no i'll do it i'll do it so i mean
that was my point in my time in my life
is i have this opportunity and i don't
want to [ __ ] let it go so i had to
like try my hardest and
pretty much put my life on the line
the thing too it was so great like i was
talking with preston lacy the other day
and and i was like
like what because you genuinely are the
the breakout star of the movie you know
i i i really think that that's safe to
say and i was freshman i was saying like
dude like poopies doesn't even have like
in jackass forever like that one
signature solo bit that's like
like you don't even put it in they
didn't put it in what was it it was
called i'll show i'll show me yeah i'll
show me did i love that what is that oh
dude he's standing on a step ladder with
a [ __ ] sledgehammer he's on the top
right he goes oh show me he swings the
stepladder down snogs it out from
beneath him
shoot maybe people don't realize a lot
of that ended up in the movie
that was what that's like all the stuff
that dirt x plays you did the the airbag
musical chairs
man does the flip was from the test
shoot yeah the dumb dumb game was from
the testing
that was the test shoot the human ramp
with the yep all the guys stacked
[ __ ] done in those two days it was crazy
yeah
yeah it's insane
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride
the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]